[Music]
James Wong trapped inside a puppeteers
prop trunk when he was a child
discount Candace Cameron ransacked room
crayon all over the wall and mirror is
this the work of a demon-possessed doll
in a formula any normal person with
normal eyesight would have seen this
being known on the floor the very
instant they opened the door especially
if you're sort of expecting a 2-foot
doll to be the one knocking you wanted
to get inside of you
well that's no different from most guys
I know when it comes to nurses wait did
this classroom just see the same thing
we saw you know the demon leaving all
those messages and drawing stuff in
crayon or did they just see an amateur
film of a boring interview with nurses
where they simply talked about the demon
doll for 10 minutes it seems unlikely
the whole class would be this intrigued
by a boring interview unless they saw
exactly what we saw but they couldn't
have unless the nurses re-enacted
everything and the Warrens somehow got
their hands on modern cameras and color
correction look I'm all for token
international characters in film but
when you put the black guy next to the
middle-eastern lady all you do is call
attention to how many white people are
in your shot questions what college is
this in the 1960s that has almost no
black people but also an extremely high
interest in demon possession enough that
the room is completely full in nearly
every single attendee raises their hand
I mean it's got to be Notre Dame right
there's no way in the world anyone would
be able to tell which person he's
pointing at particularly when half the
audience has their hand up reading
really slow reading James Wan does not
know how to scare you without first
telling you it's all true how many kids
do these two have like halfway to a
reality show at this point family moves
into a creepy new house and the teenager
hates it did the dog senses evil before
humans do and there's a music box cliche
hey I like one-shots as much as the next
film nerd shouldn't you at least have a
reason for doing one or interesting
characters or action for us to watch
while you're doing it you got pizza
delivered out here in the middle of
nowhere in the 1970s damn your father of
the years also how did this huge family
not finish off one pizza there's like
one slice per person with a pizza that
size it can't really be that expensive
when they can barely handle one freaking
pizza I mean sounds like you could feed
this family on a can of beets this is
just like Marley and Me only I
haven't had time to care about this dog
yet well why not just throw them in an
incinerator destroy well that would only
destroy the vessel pretty clearly said
the demons can't possess things they can
only possess people demonic spirits
don't possess things and you said ghosts
don't even have the power to manipulate
these vessels now you're making it sound
like there are demons inside these
things and that burning them would be
like turning off the containment grid
and Ghostbusters hell in fact if these
things are just conduits wouldn't it be
better if they were destroyed you can't
go into this room no matter what
remember right kids always follow that
kind of advice you may be an expert on
demons but you are a terrible father I
guess a Nancy isn't freaked out about
the door closing on its own even though
she couldn't see the demon demon makes
declaration that it wants the family
dead tests door creaking Asst and slam
ability to prove it means business
nobody else in the entire household
hears all these pictures fall down the
stairs
but when Christine screamed earlier
everyone woke up and wonder what the
hell was going on what idiot in the
right mind does this I mean I know it's
in movies all the time but even if you
don't believe in ghosts or demon
hauntings do you still want to yell out
and give away your position to a burglar
or rapists convenient of the demon to
wait a whole week until the father has
literally just returned from a trucking
run to Florida before doing any actual
Latin is a dead language no one truly
knows what good Latin sounds like
backwards or forwards my neighbor Jackie
is always mocking the Holy Trinity
whenever she comes over to borrow sugar
[Music]
that's because they're mocking the state
of Wyoming I wonder if in a couple
hundred years horror movies will explore
the spooky occurrences from playing
around with a dusty Sega Genesis when
she sees Rory in the mirror shouldn't
the wall be in reverse position since
she's looking at him in the mirror when
she turns around to look normally
everything's in the exact same position
I'm afraid that's not gonna help leaving
the house isn't gonna help cliche can
you get haunted it's like steppin on gum
you take it with you yeah nothing ever
gets rid of gum claimed her love to say
and cursed anyone who tried to take her
land and hung herself it sounds to me
like you could just leave them if he
didn't own the land any more than this
Bathsheba demon with ghosts wouldn't
have a beef so what was the original to
Baker farm has since been subdivided and
sold off the demon who hates its land
being taken apparently has no problem
with the government that is subdividing
it and selling it to people who are
completely unaware of the curse there
was another boy who drowned in a pond
here
I guess the demon which was happy with
his parents living in the house nothing
happened to them and worked as a maid in
a neighboring home but the maids
employers were a ok people who took her
land we think maybe the maid stole
silverware we're still not sure she took
land yet did they even rewind this tape
even if the demon can activate the tape
recorder it still has to abide by the
laws of 1970s audio technology the
family mysteriously took a group photo
at the beach without including beach or
ocean in the background so just so that
later Lorraine could show off her
amazing ability to figure out that they
were at the beach pretty far out isn't
it yeah it's characters awkwardly talked
70 slang to remind you that you're in
the 70s so noted sir what I had to go
apparently no one heard Brad go into the
bathroom in the first place how come
when the ghost hunters first show up at
the house the family's already sleeping
collectively in the living room
downstairs with bedding and mattresses
and everything and then when the intern
kid is setting up the cameras all the
beds have bedding and mattresses on them
again but then that night when they get
ready to observe the haunting the beds
are script of bedding and mattresses
Brad get the camera oh come on this
footage from a 1971 portable video
camera is better than my iPhone earlier
in the movie you were told that the
oppression stage is where the victim is
broken down and left in a weakened state
so that the demon can take over for the
third stage possession but in the
previous scene Carolyn doesn't look too
broken down she looks pretty chipper for
someone who's on the brink of a demon
possession
geez not one broken bone that was a
nasty fall looks like the worst thing
that happened was that she got a little
dirty even the music Mach survived
without breaking movie is excellent at
sudden loudness did they just pull the
parents get home at the exact same time
the child is having a haunting crisis
move twice in one film without a retro
Satana wait Dini training and exorcism
training in Latin God I condemn you back
to hell wait this English work now car
batteries in the 70s did not last long
enough for all these headlights to still
be on in the morning I'd like to know
the story of the demonic teapot and that
evil telescope more reading
I condemn you back to hell
[Music]
with pen is blue it is blue okay who
wants to go down the creepy tunnel
inside the tomb first
[Music]
do you remember what you said to me on
our wedding night up inside my mouth if
you want to live well that's to keep
those doors from banging at night
otherwise you sleep long just like
[Music]